her dad passed away first in 1975 and
when the mom passed away they got joint
gravestones so she then buried it in the
backyard if I murdered a bunch of people
and that was my back out that's exactly
what I would say too
[Music]
hey what's up guys Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up guys different angle different
look I like it I like it it feels good
this is this is cool this is cool guys
this is the dope as usual podcast we're
gonna talk about live drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today is our fan favorite solo
episode it's just me and Marty there's
nobody in the room we can just talk
about whatever we want to talk about
let's get yeah let's get started because
there's a lot to talk about there's a
lot to catch up on I got some fire over
here so I'm really excited yeah oh yeah
oh you were here when I started
we'll talk about that too um we'll talk
about that too but before we get started
do us a favor if you're in the chat if
you're at home if you're on your TV go
on your phone get on the episode press
like it really helps circulate the video
helps everything we appreciate you guys
um let's get into oh hold on stop
remembering that way 50 episodes I'm
trying we haven't really smoked that
much today I wouldn't worked out this
morning and didn't get home
um before we start our Instagram dope as
usual podcast boom pop up man there it
is on the screen uh go follow that also
our Twitter dope as usual podcast follow
that we don't really do too much Twitter
me and you but we do a lot of Instagram
so get on there support the page we
appreciate you guys and we always drop
fan questions so you might see your
question featured on the show we just
ask on other social media platforms so
if you guys want to be involved in the
show more and get your question on you
if you have something you really want to
ask us drop it in the comments and you
find out stuff early we drop Clips yeah
teasers and stuff on there so you got to
be on Instagram to be a real fan of the
podcast when I was a little 11 year old
boy I was at the flea market and I saw
this this you know I'm buying bootle
DVDs and I go what is this tape what
basketball what is that I was introduced
to anyone mixtape
I grew up on it I thought I was hot
sauce and escalade's body for real I
really but short and uh that's all I did
that's all I cared about I know you were
a basketball fanatic all I cared about
as a kid was skateboarding toys and
trying to do the the Kobe thing before
right back I can do it I can dribble my
ass off you know that you guys know that
other than that I lose right you played
basketball you are white-skinned you
loved and one who else was the white kid
from and one who are we supposed to have
on the show today
I'll professor professor not Professor X
all right Professor you guys know what
I'm talking about the white dude I know
a lot of people I don't know what
professors but yes you do yes you do
don't act like you don't what was it
he's been a doubt don't act like you
don't know about drugs when you do you
have to realize like certain people are
legends to us us yes not necessarily to
the rest of the world but I don't care
professor's a legend everybody like to
everyone I don't know come on figure it
out you guys know who the professor is
if you don't watch and one he's the dude
on YouTube that shakes everybody to the
ground though I do with it with the
designs sometimes he dresses like
Spider-Man
before YouTube he was crossing Earth all
right on the and one mixtape tour so you
really gotta appreciate like and one is
the first viral thing before YouTube it
went viral through four legs and then I
want to legitimize DVD you had to go
we've gone over this you had to get the
shoes and the we've done a whole episode
about it we've talked about this
constantly okay so it was viral before
viral like Kimbo Slice like before right
before that era yeah the same type of
thing but it went from being straight
street basketball to mainstream
Nationwide tour that's what you saw the
evolution from volume two to volume four
they're like okay we got money now we're
going on tour so they went City to City
the deepest hoods they can find in each
City hop out on the tour bus we're
playing whoever you got and one for the
DVD that's where they found Professor
you got that little town remember out in
Oregon little town a little tiny kid oh
yeah you know his little headbanders
won't play basketball he was a teenager
well he was a kid he was the whitest kid
within a 10 mile radius he's the
shortest the skinniest the fraless the
youngest and the fastest he played
against them and ends up getting put on
this tour I watched the whole thing I
remember watching it like before
American Idol he could vote remember
call in my grandma was all about Justin
Guarini in the season one I remember his
name because she had to like call in for
Justin Guarini for me all right on the
landline on the landline non-stop so
before that yeah before you could vote
Apple shook so many fools he got on the
tour as a kid I mean I'm a Streetball
for real I just remember watching like
he can do it all right I suck and then
the most legendary thing all the time I
don't know if you saw this Madison
Square Garden oh yeah of course the full
MSG he comes down Mecca of all
basketball
three-pointer to win from damn near half
court as a young boy looks like cam out
there he does look like cab he does look
like cam a lot so he was just legendary
to me I live vicariously through her I
do too but hot sauce is my I always wore
bigger shirts when I play basketball so
I can do the way you throw it on your
shirt goes around
when I had that down I never shook
anybody with it yeah but everybody's oh
that's all it was about that's all that
mattered if you did do it in a real game
this kid's gonna want to fight for sure
yeah I've gotten punched in the face uh
for basketball games I've got elbow in
the mouth still one we've got a lot of
questions about that for him yes yes oh
come on man you don't get schooled by
this little young kid I bet you he's
gotten smacked so many times by people
for he's a fine line in the Streetball
between disrespecting somebody and doing
your [__] out there it's a very fine
line a special face off the forehead no
you gotta swing on yourself yeah I'm
gonna hit you how many people are
watching how many people react I'm used
to be like that a Delaware Park in
Buffalo for you you used to do this
while it was going on it was a fine
online so yesterday during the live chat
of the little Duvall episode we get a
text and it's just oh my heart broke
this is says the professor broke his
foot he cannot come tomorrow
I wish I had the sound board to express
I know we need to break I'm sorry but we
need to bring the bag we gotta figure
out how to get it back but you need a
soundboard yeah has to happen I know I'm
in the chat with you guys I know you
guys asked for the soundboard too we'll
bring it back
I was so sad but I had to keep just
Trucking doing the and I was laughing
through the episode but I know I was on
the phone with Ted Talk people in the
middle of the episode get this
devastating news
Marty got some and one balls yes so
we're gonna decide for us like we didn't
know each other as kids we're both fans
I'm a fan I am excited it's like Ricky
Williams we came on like oh it's so true
this is like my Tony Hawk episode you
know what I'm saying for everyone out
there I get it yeah I mean you get it
when you see somebody like
wow as a kid I just wanted to be you but
the special thing about Professor is he
just took it up still going and it's
even more relevant now because Netflix
just came out with the N1 documentaries
I watched it when I you want to go watch
that yeah brush up on that before the
episode because he is coming he's coming
next month he's just he's injured of all
the times and I I said it on Twitter I'm
like I'm gonna do my best to cross the
professor after the episode there's a
basketball here and then it was like oh
he broke his foot he saw my tween guys
no he didn't oh that was my joke all
right that's for me it's like saying yo
yeah right well like I'm like chunk all
right Michael Jackson did not come to
use the bathroom but his sister did
that's my life right now
but yeah right
[Music]
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our newest sponsors and
this is fume so guys be smart don't
start kick the habit 100 times you've
heard it from your parents your
grandparents from teachers with all that
yet we still continue to have these bad
habits our sponsor fumes on a mission to
accelerate the breakup from these bad
habits that consume far too many of us
fume is a natural diffusive device that
utilizes plant matter and Behavioral
Science to help you trade out these
negative bad habits for a positive one
guys fume is not a vape it's a
non-electronic device trying to help you
transform from your negative habits
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a vape fume uses
core is infused with plants like
peppermint and cinnamon for delicious
natural flavor guys I already tried this
with my friends and honestly it's I wish
that smell was in my entire house the
easiest way to quit a bad habit is to
replace it with a positive one and fume
is perfectly designed to help you do
that fume's goal is to make this
enjoyable and make switching easy they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you that have
successfully switched from products that
just didn't work for them had to try
perfume.com today and save 10 off on the
journey pack with code Dau the journey
pack comes with three unique flavors and
the new version 2 fume to help
kick-start your positive habits and
remember that's tri-fume that's try
fum.com remember to use our code at
checkout that's Dau to get 10 off stop
those bad habits leave them in 2022
start 2023 the right way
[Music]
foreign
so real quick all right I finally toured
cbx one of our favorite my favorite Wii
Brands finally toured it
this is the cush Mount okay now I
already you already put me on the cbx
we've only been fans of this I've only
been fans never met any of them shout
out to ratchet man for hooking me up one
thing I'm going to say that I love first
off I never seen nobody be more serious
about their weed just that's right off
the bat
they had the rooms to go into the rooms
because you know you're not supposed to
let light leak for all the Growers out
there there's a black room you walk into
like a dark room for developing photos
then you go in I had to open a thing get
in a box and it shot me with all this
air and this clean stuff and I have my
clothes the air you'll see the Vlog
they're serious I had to put these boots
on a whole suit they were so serious and
the thing that I loved the most Marty I
think I told you one of the owners used
to be in Fabrics so he had factories
with all these older Mexican ladies you
know grandmas and aunts they were just
doing sewing covet came he couldn't keep
it up and where he had to close down but
instead of firing them all and letting
them go he taught him all the weed game
so when I walked in there was nothing
but like my aunts and grandmas just
trim enough and it was Valentine's Day
so they had a party so everyone was like
having a [__] [__] Hardy I've
never seen a happier facility in my
entire life and nobody was walking
around piss nobody was just walking
around like taking dance like people
were there to work hell stoked and when
I walked in the trim room there was
music and everybody's just like laughing
oh my God man that's why the Wii's good
I love that they're happy growing it you
know love that so uh that's this so
before we get on that's a different type
of Team than if you just like open up in
downtown L.A now hiring signs it's all
people and all the people that are using
doing the grow are their nephews and
grandsons yeah yeah it sounds like a
family operation going on it's so sick I
was very pleasantly surprised man
um so yeah that's this so let's get on
to uh and hold on can we talk about uh
you were saying like the process of not
actually touching the flower okay so
they do like the stem trim where they
hold the stem
and they trim the nug they don't take
the nugs off the plant they trim it
while it's on so you never touch the
trichomes and I would imagine this takes
way more time that's why people don't
not that it takes more time
it does it takes more care like so much
is that a lighter yeah that's all I got
oh yeah
um so yeah they do every nug looks
pristine all the trichomes are not
squished they're no like flat parts of
the nug it's not roughed up it's
like a picture in your jar so that's why
it looks so good if you're really about
your weed and you're trying to be the
biggest snob possible yeah
should you be wearing like gloves or
some [__] when you're like how are you
keeping all those trichomes from when
you grind it up they're all gloved
masked suited everything everyone in the
facility
you if you go outside you have to go
back through what I'm saying are you
ruining it then when you get it home and
you just break it up with your fingers
some people some people like to hand
grind some people like to break it up
and feel the weed I get that when I have
crazy weed I will Leaf by leaf that
[__] into a joint yeah because I don't
want to crush them they're probably
preserve that's what I'm saying
though if I got time other than that I
will throw a whole ass nug into a
grinder yeah and just squish it up
sometimes but most the time I break it
down I take this these damage yeah then
I grind it but this is me yeah you're
the first person I ever heard talk about
doing it different ways and Shout out
yeah there's so much grind for my balls
yeah you can't you can't you gotta do
the grind like this with the balls I
can't do the grinder with bowls it
tastes different don't know why leave it
in the comments you understand it does I
realize that afterwards 100 it's like
broiling and baking and boiling there's
just different you can do the same piece
of meat three different ways you know
what I'm saying
um so let's get on to this this little
topic today we are not going crazy we're
trying to stay a little topical and
actually do
what somebody would do in podcasts you
know like maybe talk about things on
earth that are going on Marty you want
to get it going yeah
I mean so we're coming in here season
three episode four
and we've been noticeably leveling up
with each episode we move Studios came
in here now we're up all the way to
where we wanted to be really and it took
a lot we're really grateful for our team
here coming into this new situation we
knew there'd be like an adjustment
period and trying to like you know when
you have something that works it's scary
to like change anything 100 but I'm
really glad we did and I feel really
great about how strong our team is now
and how we're moving now and like just
the way things are going so you know any
comments that we had like we're always
acutely aware of the quality of the show
and that's our utmost importance you
never got to worry about that we're
always going to push for everything to
always be done to the utmost as far as
the show goes like the first you talk
about the first two episodes people like
yo the quality what the [__] what's the
sound we had to dial things in now the
quality did you see that last quality
last episode I'm back on track we're
ready to go we're doing our thing that's
something that's never going to stop
we're going to always keep improving
little things and you're gonna see like
check out all the small little remote
sets they throw up when they're out
doing events they just shot with Charles
Barkley with the sick purple lights all
in the stage and stuff like that so
we're getting there yeah and also as it
extends into guest booking and our last
episode with Lil Duvall season three
episode three
now which was a great episode which was
an awesome episode actually I really
enjoyed the episode
but it was a little tricky because we
got word of this news about these tweets
that it was like as we were coming into
the studio I was on the way here like
there's some weird tweets but they're
basically they're like kind of being
taken out of context I've been working
with comedians sorry for about 10 years
so I understand especially 10 years ago
yeah comedians say dark outlandish stuff
oh yeah
so we saw the tweets about like the
Justin Bieber thing and while it was
meaning the tweets were as if he was a
Justin Bieber fan like
um he's basically saying hey these moms
why is it okay for all these moms to
bring their daughters to Ogle this boy
it's weird bringing your little daughter
to augle this kid like I can't wait till
she's 18. go go for him it's he was kind
of like poking fun of like yeah that's
gross
and then just started tweeting as if he
was with the mom like oh I can't wait
for him not talking about his own kid I
mean it was in the context if you didn't
know that you'd be like a lot of people
were coming at me like you're a piece of
[__] for having this guy I'm like I'm on
the drive to the studio I just found out
that some stuff happened and then I
would talk we talked to everyone like
wait
you mean comedy
he was going hard on these fools I get
it I get it from that perspective so I
kept having to copy paste it to people
like bro please just do a little
research
and like chill out what else you want me
to do yeah also don't watch the episode
if you don't want to you should though
it was a it was a good one he was
hilarious that guy was really funny I
was on and off camera and that guy was
badass while he was sitting here before
the episode like he got him his daughter
called him they had a conversation it
wasn't just like they look like they had
an awesome relationship yeah I didn't
realize I didn't connect that so after
my
because we had to address it because so
many of you are dming us chill do some
research and then you know yeah and I
understand there's more there's more you
could go back there's probably first of
all like we said in the shows too it's
posted on Instagram alone 30 000 some
odd times there's other tweets out there
too that don't have to do with the
Justin Bieber thing people were tagging
us and stuff in like I don't know
yeah if we would have you know had all
this research before the episode you
guys got to understand like still wait a
minute yeah nothing there was like oh
you're going to jail over some weird
yeah like oh you're just because there
is like some [__] there is a fine line
with a lot of the comedians yes I like
Anthony jeselnak for pushing it and
doing dark humor maybe not all
communities do dark humor
I get it but unless it was like some uh
some Delia [__] it's different exactly
different there's a difference between
people that kind of like get canceled
for actual like actions that they're out
doing and then kind of blame it on their
comedy versus the other way like no it's
just comedy now I'm getting in trouble
for it but yo I didn't say that now
cancelable now because people don't like
joking like that anymore even though
like I don't I'm not done with those
kind of jokes either let's just say that
like I don't think it was funny but it's
a community that's what he thinks is
funny it's funny there's a thing where
are you fear makes one of the people the
day they die yeah there's a lot of
people do a lot of things for comedy uh
you wouldn't understand like I would
never say that I would never say that
bro yeah get that you have your fan base
yeah there it is a swing and a miss
all right let's just say that was a bomb
also the show goes on that we've done
100 smart episodes you know like we're
we're never gonna let somebody on the
show that we think is a bad person
exactly or like that we don't we're
never gonna just do it we've already
passed on that before with people that
we're like ready to book somebody and
we're like
but at the same time like you know like
I said earlier young Mike got out of
jail moments before coming to the
episode like we can't
judge everybody the world's biggest coke
dealer on here we've had the world's
biggest jewel thief ever on here too
talking about knocking fools asleep in
jail in prison federal prison taking
assets which is great it's awesome
that's why the show is live drugs
problems and everything in between guys
there's a lot of stuff and we're not
saying like those tweets are hilarious I
didn't think they were funny yeah I'm
either but that's it yeah so we just
want to address it and then um yeah yeah
it's still a great episode of course on
and off that guy was badass I think he
was hilarious it was an awesome episode
so if I had to come across and be like
yo I've never met him I have he was cool
yeah he was very nice to us
um all right let's get on to a little
story so I was driving
to go get some stuff and uh I just see
Marty's Instagram
and at first I thought do you gotta move
do you have to move Marty is this on
hold for an investigation
what happened and then I watched the
whole I was stuck
I was invested so can you please give us
the breakdown of what happened at your
new house Mark you guys already know
what he's digging up his backyard for a
pool yeah Excavating yeah what did you
ask somebody commented this only would
happen to you of course if that happened
to me like of course
yeah yeah so we're done with the house
we moved on to the backyard we've been
at it for months they went in and had to
completely dig up our entire backyard
except for
imagine a giant square and only the
upper right corner doesn't get dug
everything else gets completely
Unearthed and it's changed levels and we
dug out the pool they've been moving
wheel barrels of dirt out of the house
for weeks
so there's one patch of grass my
backyard yeah I really like it's a
complete restructure and design in this
backyard the same yeah no I mean
different property
it is you would never you would never
look at it and think like oh my God yeah
great job it's crazy they're doing a
really good job it's insane so
as they're doing this I get a text from
the dude that runs the design company of
a tombstone
like and he goes is there anything you
want to tell us bro as a joke you know
so as they're digging in this one little
area that they didn't excavate they find
a man's Tombstone which is shocking you
know it's not something you what year
was he boarded
1899 Hocus Pocus here imagine being born
in 1899 and what the world is
dope stoked yeah it's pretty less
worries but pretty people maybe polio
takes you out you lived a long life this
guy lived he was uh seven six
yeah no 75 so yeah 76 years old damn
sorry you didn't want to say the tip
came out
damn it Marty I didn't even think of it
I missed swinging a mess go I [__] up
so this dude and the worker made a good
comment they Unearthed those gravestone
and the dudes are like this dude lived
through you know two World Wars The
Great Depression
no modern medicine really like you died
son okay so there's a gravestone buried
in our backyard and obviously the next
thought after that once you realize that
is is there a casket to go with this
gravestone buried next to my pool now is
this the crow did he get up and leave if
there is a casket is there multiple cat
is this an old graveyard you said
dancing oh not dead dancing are you the
fool from coach
and is this Poltergeist
so I want everybody to let me know if
you just bought a house and invested
like you said all your life savings into
a house and you found that your backyard
was in fact
a cemetery
there's not a cemetery far from you no
there's one close very close yeah
there's one really close uh would you
move immediately
you let us know but right now at this
point in the story hotel that night
because by all the comments I feel like
people would be really freaked out
and if somebody if somebody said like
can you Matt okay I'm Gonna Leave This
in suspense for a moment could you
imagine being in your pool
you're Six Feet Under
yeah and then so somebody put in my head
and then just a hand now you're
imagining hands grabbing at your feet
things like that zombie stuff
Beetlejuice stuff going on
I'm thinking I'm not even like that I
don't even I don't get all I mean
superstitious I'll go off Vibes like I
don't want to be in a room somebody
killed themselves and for instance or
some horrible stuff happened in like
that's just me I don't like that type of
stuff but
I was really like thinking what are we
gonna do like obviously the police my
neighbor's a sheriff obviously the
police are going to be having to get
involved if there's bodies in this
backyard
if they were sketchy bodies they
probably wouldn't have a gravestone also
is what I was thinking so we start
digging straight down in front of the
tombstone me and the two workers and
they're like they they do this for a
living and they're like we've never seen
anything like this before
hold on for one second just for
reference you're swimming in a pool in
the deep end oh God there's a layer of
pool concrete and behind it there's dead
bodies
you don't know nope
would you be okay you ever seen that
movie house from the 80s or 90s no I
didn't see it house party no how
yeah University house party remember
Kitty plays in the backyard no Martin
Drive a house the horror movie never
mind damn it
anyway I ain't swimming in that pool
bring it back to Vietnam it's like house
so I'm feeling
so my feelings because I feel okay in
the sense that we excavated most the
yard already if this is a graveyard some
sort of burial ground because here's the
other kicker homeboy died in 75 my house
was built in 76.
so that was just another factor that we
realized right away that didn't help
like someone decided to build land on a
grave site yeah a year later
this investigation is getting deeper
continue this is a whole lifetime movie
kinda it is yeah I'll take that yeah
it's it's up there with my uh bomb story
yeah
okay sorry go your Sheriff next door
neighbor does what for you gets involved
I go over it
I go over and ask him and his wife if
they have any clue who this dude is
because we have this his name he's on a
greater stuff yeah they've lived there
since the 70s since the 90s oh okay okay
so they don't recognize the name but I
you know he comes over and checks it out
and while he we're doing that the the
workers started digging straight down
it's killing me because I don't want to
give these dudes any extra work they're
doing so much and I'm like let me do it
they're not letting me do it but like
you tried to dig yourself yeah you're so
polite I was feeling horrible I was
standing there like asking them to let
me do it because this is some extras but
they were really intrigued I get it it
was like we were searching for like a
pirate treasure or something
don't worry
so uh
my kids mortified April's mortified
[Laughter]
so we started just digging and you would
think even as professional diggers
Dickens six feet down is not an easy
task it's just a shovel
I've never really well you've shoveled
Stone yeah
it's way easier than just dirt though oh
for sure but you've dug more snow than
in your life than those Builders yeah oh
that's a fact yeah for sure so you know
okay yeah maybe I should have took that
damn child
you would have Sonic
well we got probably about five feet
down and every time he hit a rock pink I
think I'm like my heart drops I can only
imagine how many bowls have you had
already snuck on the side of the house
because it's been so expensive to do
this to begin with I'm running through
my head like all right when he finds
this we're gonna clearly have to just
take out the rest of this dirt how much
is that gonna cost
uh after you already build the pool yeah
like
God knows what if it's like I don't know
what if it's deep
the pool's probably 10 feet total I
don't know maybe less than that
but what you got to understand about
backyards in California is it was just
like sand and sediment the dude's like
this this area was underwater not that
long ago they had to bring dirt this is
all like you can see when they dug the
pool it's all different kinds of dirt
going down
this was the desert you know I guess
what people say like a lot of my
backyard was just sand once they dug it
up
what
what it's weird I ain't gonna even try
to put my head around that that was
confusing as hell
yeah they had to bring in dirt like you
know how they bring in Audrey's I get it
there's only one palm tree that's
indigenous this area of California two
palm trees you know that Marty I don't
know how do you know that I looked it up
you looked it up okay all right
they bring them in you know I get it I
get it so anyway we dig down and then
April and that time found out like found
this dude's like obituary basically
uh she's in Buffalo she's been in you
know you found the obituary of the man
that was in your yard yes
yep it said on the gravestone loving
father and husband so I felt good about
the guy okay but that's the default
that's a default like he was a bastard
at a drunk loving father let him go I
don't have it I guess you're gonna say
it yeah that's default
yeah you're right always to let you hit
the joint twice you're right you know
what I mean it's almost like saying
nothing yeah it's almost like the eulogy
but anybody want to say something
done
nothing else
sorry continue we're not talking [__]
about this man I'm very sorry no
no no so it was underwater what if he
was a pirate no I think he was speaking
like I'm kidding yeah okay
well I had to yeah I had to go back in
my mind how long ago was this [__]
underwater Oh you're speaking like
hundreds of years okay so the sheriff
yeah that's what so the sheriff calls
the previous owner of the house which
why does he have the number is crazy
because they were neighbors for a long
time but I get that are you gonna keep
your [__] you know what older people
your neighbor's number my Grandma had
the Rolodex yeah the black
take it back and
he he goes yeah I talked to the woman
that used to own this house and after he
told me what she said it dawned on me
wow that is the perfect excuse me
[Laughter]
stop digging we're gonna find a [__]
family
so she said
her dad passed away first in 1975.
shortly thereafter the mom passed away
and when the mom passed away they got
joint gravestones they both got put on
one unistone and then they took his
Stone away and she didn't want to throw
it away so she then buried it in the
backyard which sounds weird just when I
say it out loud but I mean I could see
that happening also if I murdered a
bunch of people and that was my back out
that's exactly what I would say too hmm
then again if I murder people why would
I have their gravestone murdered you
wouldn't keep the grapes yeah you
wouldn't keep the graves yeah you
wouldn't want to keep the two next to
each other no not at all
so that sounds like a perfect excuse
to tell a sheriff dad tell the sheriff
oh my old Sheriff neighbors gone yeah no
he he died I buried it but if he died in
76 she just happened to bury 75 75. she
buried it oh could have been flip flop
got you it makes sense could have been
any time oh she could have got she got
away with murder I think but she got
away with [__] murder part of me
wants to just dig the rest of it I think
you should just let it be yeah and yeah
no bones we dug down in front of where
the gravestone was where the body casket
would be
deep there was nothing there the sheriff
came out said there's probably nothing
there and we let it be we put the put
the gravestone back in Buried it out of
respect yeah you got to put it back but
I get the bearing thing when I broke my
first pipe I told you the story about me
running over my pipe my first one when I
got it from Mexico correct
no are you serious running over I don't
I don't recognize any of those keywords
oh my God really
I don't think so
so one time I went to Mexico with my
Uncle Greg with my family Michael Gray
we went around Tijuana and just looked
at stuff
and I found this pipe and don't sell
anything to you it doesn't matter what
your age is you could be 12 but you only
want to come to the bar like
they kept asking me going to the strip
club I was like 12 13 I'm like damn
now I can and they just kept walking I
was like I am with my family and I'm
scared I'm a little kid anyway I walked
by this guy was selling glass Pisces
Mexico and I'm like oh my God there's
pipes in reach like I've never been in
this glass store I'm not allowed never
been in a head shop I can't go I've
never been to the smoke shop and if I
was with my mom to get cigarettes or
something and I'm not going to look
around on the phone and throw my get my
cover away so I just like oh water pipes
and walk out you know
um
so I'm like oh my God right oh I want to
buy one right now right just because
like nobody has a pipe I'm in ninth
ninth grade no one's got a [__] piece
no one has a glass piece I'll forever
have the glass piece we can all get high
for real and I had to make bongs and
what I did was I looked at my Uncle Greg
and went over to him he's looking to
watch me all right I'm gonna look at
those posters and I backed up
and I sprinted around the flea market
down this little spot where I saw it and
I asked him hey how much is that and he
told me and I go okay and I 20 bucks or
15 bucks and it was a wooden pipe ready
wooden pipe it inside was plastic it was
the manuf you guys know what I'm talking
about but
it was a log a steamroller
right but it was a log with a naked
chick but she was also carved and she
was around like hanging off the log
around the bowl and there was like a
metal bowl that came out a cheap little
Eight dollar pipe now okay but back
there I saw it remember in Wayne's World
when he stares the guitar that's exactly
what happened to me but it was Daylight
I looked
like can I buy that right now and he
wrapped it in newspaper I'm like the
give me a all right gave me a newspaper
like bro this is supposed to be a
concealed I shoved that [__] in the
front of my pants and I started walking
back to my uncle gray and right when I
started walking he's looking for me hey
no the poster there's too much he's like
all right he's like let's walk back
across the border right what happened to
the Border have you ever been to the
border of Mexico you ever walked over
there no sir you searched I would
imagine all right you get searched uh
but on the Walking part back then when I
was a kid it wasn't too bad and I was a
kid Michael Greg looks like a politician
like he speaks perfect Spanish you know
what I mean okay but he looks more like
a white dude but he he's Mexican as [__]
and uh
I spoke Spanish to him like oh yeah it's
my nephew Sarah says there's nothing to
let me walk right through and the whole
time I'm like
like shaking like oh my God what if I
get caught this [__] Bible I was
tripping and my Uncle Greg the the
upstanding of my uncles yeah he's the
businessman if you guys went to Ted Talk
the guy that looked like a politician
with the gray hair the blue jacket that
was my Uncle Greg that I took a picture
with that was him he doesn't look like
my uncle he was like George Clooney's
cousin and uh
Ted Talk coming out soon too yeah TED
Talks coming soon and approved it's
coming it's going down it's happening
um
so
I walk across the border I'm about to
[__] myself and we make it across might
I am now officially the guy with the
pipeout now it's sick we're all looking
high like oh my we don't have to make
bongs you know I mean like I'm like just
thinking
across the border so I get back and go
to my homie Joe's damn that was just how
I got the pipe I tell a lot of backstory
sorry
fast forward I used to steal my
grandma's car all the time
I know it sounds terrible but my grandma
had really nice Cadillac she'd always
get a cat new Cadillac but she's in the
country yeah I would steal that [__]
all the time my Grandma and Grandpa are
truck drivers I know when they're gone I
know when they're coming home
I know their routes I know where their
routes are I know where they're going to
be this is they don't come home early oh
hell no they don't normally work and
then they come home yeah I know exactly
where they're going to be but everyone
knows me and I can't be riding around in
a brand new white Cadillac with the gold
on the gold little trims that's what my
grandma did and then she had a burgundy
one anyway I would steal that [__] I
know she kept a spare key I would take
it and I'd go across if you guys are
from Merced
um it's Yosemite you know how there's a
plaza right there used to not go through
right there by the by the weed uh
dispensary right behind the we dispatch
through that field I used to drive
through that field off of Highway 59 I
drive through that field before it was
developed go to my friend Joe's house I
go to Joe's house we get [__] up and I
drive home it was just anything smokable
outside I could have did that but
being at you know I was like I got the
Cadillac and the pie
right
so I'm coming back I do this [__] every
as much I've done it a hundred times I'm
doing it and this one day I'm going back
through the field how about I just stop
for the security truck and I see
security I'm like oh bro that's my trail
I go there's no there's not a real
street I'm just driving through a field
although whose field It Is by driving
through the field to get to 59 before it
connected and I'd go back the way
because I don't want to get in trouble a
baby face you know what I am now but I'd
be at 14 I look like a baby I'm getting
pulled over I'm getting pulled over and
uh I'm like [__] I can't go that way so
I had to go all the way three miles back
to Old Lake Road I know I'm just
explaining for people that are around
there come all the way back by the dump
and come through because there was no
other Road Yosemite did not go through
this is before the land was developed I
get back
I pull up I'm about to park in the
garage there's a long driveway and I'm
like oh no
that's my stepmom's car
but I close the garage when I leave you
know okay there's a garage she parked
outside it's like does she see me maybe
she's in the room because my little
sister was little like maybe she's
changing her maybe she's watching TV
then you have a gravel driveway you know
the day it's two in the afternoon I'm
creeping up like oh God no no no
someone's gonna catch me stealing in the
car I got weed in the pipe I mean it's
over I reek oh bro come on I'm 14 years
old 15. so did you leave no I I I
honestly thought that I'm like but I
have the car maybe she didn't look at
the garage because why would she
yeah so it's like maybe I could sneak my
ass in so I've crept
[__] Andy Bernard from the office
under five miles an hour I kept and I
opened the garage and I parked and right
when I parked I closed the garage did
you have to get out and open it or she
had no no I have a button okay I closed
the garage it's a farmhouse out in the
cuts but we have a garage door opener
right we do we do grandma always has and
I put the pipe right underneath the top
right when I get I just put the pipe
down
and I come out the back of my grandma's
work garage and I come through the
garage hey what's up to my stepmom and
she goes oh hi she's watching TV with
the baby and she's like where were you I
was like I was in the back
wow I was gone she had no idea I know
exactly how my grandma Parks they're
truck drivers they know how to drive
they Park the same way they've been
driving a truck for 50 years I have to
park the car I just parked I didn't line
it up exactly how she does it I know my
grandma she's gonna notice if her car is
a centimeter off we're all drivers in my
family uh like I didn't park like that
you ever see your car like I would never
Park this bad you know what I mean so
I'm like no I gotta go I waited a couple
minutes and I reparked it and right when
I parked at her what the [__] was that
[__]
and I go and I park in my perfect I get
out I look down and go
what is that leaf the plastic Leaf
where's your plastic Leaf close the door
I look down to make sure there's no and
I do that and go
my pipe is in a cartoon Splat I forgot I
put it behind the tire when I got out I
was so focused on not getting caught I
just put it down and freaked out the car
and slithered away
and I ran over the piece
so
after she left I dropped to my knee
platoon stopped yeah I really did drop
to my mortified and I didn't yell loud
because she was there
but like quiet yeah because my stepmom
was still there she's so disappointed in
yourself I was so hurt there was so much
resin Caked Up in that [__]
it was last lowest moments coming right
after you break your [__] like dude I
ran it over right so you didn't react
this bad when you realized there was a
cat inside the car that wasn't my fault
this was my fault you know
um that's a different story
um
she left like 15 minutes later and I
went I picked it up I was cleaning the
pieces up and I put it in a white
T-shirt because I didn't have anything
and I'm like this is too sad and her
name was Maria I named that [__] the
day I was like Maria that's her name
sorry and then
sure and then uh
my stepmom left and then I buried it in
a two foot hole I dug a floor [__]
kidding me oh my God that's why I'm
talking about the grace
I didn't know this is where we were
going so to bring it back I buried it in
a T-shirt
and I marked it with a rock when I was
14 years old when I was 28 years old on
live on Instagram right before I met you
I went on live on Instagram
and I dug that [__] up on live because
it was on it was on the Thanksgiving and
I was just bored out of my mind I was
there all day I'm like let me show you
my grandma's house well you know I
always talk about it
and I dug it up on live bro
and he was still there you deserve that
Forbes article you are we're born to be
this bad it was still there so that's
what happened I dug it up on live and
everybody because a lot of [__]
think that some of my stories are fake
really at this point so many people talk
[__] to me every day
people DM me horrible [__] every day
in general like some people are so sad
with their life but it's okay it's
always like it's all right bro your day
will get better like I gotta respond
accordingly like don't worry man
whatever you're going through I respond
like that a lot whatever you're going
through bro don't worry about it I say
that a lot and people just ghost me
I've had one response like six months
later and the guy's like bro I'm sorry I
was going through some [__] blah blah
I'm like whoa I actually screenshotted
it I have it in my phone I'm like damn
favorite six months later good [__] all
right yeah anyway I buried that [__] so
that was like yeah I told you I did guys
on a story time I told you I buried it
by Brick I dug that [__] up 14 years
later bro
crazy [__] insane anyway yeah so I get
it I bearish it too
that's meaningful to you yes I'll bury
it if it meant something what'd you do
with it after you dug it up and
zombified the head of her and it's
somewhere and my grandma's I put in a
box and the rest of I threw away
just because I was like what am I Really
Gonna Do With the rest of it how many of
you guys out there know what you did
with your first piece
I don't have any clue the first bong I
ever bought I was on a pizza delivery I
dropped a pizza off two of homie I went
in I ripped like three bowls with his
friend and no no I met him I hadn't seen
him a long time met him on a delivery
came back to sell him weed I'm tripping
came back to sell him weed after I was
off work because I'm like yo I got weed
like for real Thomas I'm like you've
been gone for a couple years in college
bro uh yeah you packs like no I want
like an ounce
but you know when people leave they come
back like you have Bella pounds like
yeah sorry it's been a minute yeah we've
been gone for a while and um I came back
and his weird ass roommate had a pure
bomb same what I still have at my house
so my first piece I ever bought and it
was cracked on the side
on the on the on the Downs like right
where the downstem goes in in the hole
and I was like
how much do you want equals 200 like oh
my God it's the most expensive back when
I was a kid 200 at 18. I was like 200.
how long when I smoke blunts and I just
loved it so much I bought it and then
someone cracked it and I got it fixed in
Santa Cruz but yeah they cut the piece
and put new pieces of glasses some
welding basically my first piece I think
was one of those steel ones you got to
put the little steel screen in that
pipe of course I think we all go through
that first that first shitty piece what
football helmet was it remember the
football helmet with a bowl those pipes
I never saw that
football helmet no I'm not a little pipe
and at the end of it you don't talk
about anybody
the little metal pipes from the liquor
store they have a football helmet on and
then the bowl
oh my God is it only an inflatable
income neighborhoods in California damn
it no but anyway at the liquor stores
you could buy a little football helmet I
just got 90 people going I'm smoking
anyway like Josh will maybe give me the
car one yeah yeah yeah that but it's a
little football helmet with your
different team on it sounds sick it was
cool but that I think everybody had that
first little trash piece you ever smoke
out of a bolt
little socket with a bolt you can make a
little pipe my dad had that type oh yeah
that just sucks pipes out of the wall
and [__]
styrofoam disgusting
um anyway so yeah I bury stuff I felt so
goofy when I got my first plastic green
bong I brought that [__] like back to
the head and [__] I felt it was kind of
cool but the purple one my uncle John
did I couldn't be driving around with
those other factors yeah that's
different for you you're an exile town
you grew up different than me you grew
up different also you when you showed up
I was sneezing my ass off I'm allergic
because we're gonna share this Joy I
couldn't I could not roll another when I
was down yeah we I feel horrible you're
having a joints what this is what
Squints no for a lot of you out there
guys Squints from the sand line Squints
from Freaks and Geeks Squints from many
other things Chauncey he's a very nice
dude uh there's a little quick story I
met him when I was giving my first talk
on a stage I did a talk with Adam Mill
shout out to you at like a Cannabis Expo
they had like my picture girl that day I
was like weird what the [__] and I was
standing there and this dude walks by
and I go
is that Squid's paladoris
I just said it kind of lows I swear I
just said it to myself when he stops
what's up man I go are you for real
squint's palador so you just recognized
him as well I recognized him did you
have glasses on no but he had a
backwards hat he's he had a backwards
hat I'm like is that like bro squint's
paladors
I just said it and he turned goes up bro
I go are you for real and I said it he
goes yeah he goes
push YOLO right go
yeah man nice to meet you he goes I've
seen your [__] before
[__] [__] I was sitting there in my
head like yo shut the [__] [__] this
world no way and I was like yeah right
he goes yeah I see he was talking today
as I see your [__] go
wow my friend Darby Dr Darby you happen
to be homies with him so I'm assuming
that's how he knew I had no idea turns
out Squints is a real deal grower for
years yes husband
Squints paladors baddest man of all time
yes
it's a real deal legit grower cam
thought I was so much cooler when I let
him know that he's like a fan of the
podcast and stuff yeah I like definitely
got yeah he's all stoked
dude I mean as a kid that was
everybody's [__] man you grew up if you
didn't watch that growing up you grew up
in the 2000s or you just grew up like a
but uh anyway he's a real deal grower
foreign exotic genetics you guys ever
heard of that but that squids
out of genetics that's him those grand
Flory
all those strains that's who he breeds
with so Squints is the like when it
comes to like hey no cameras like pot no
podcast grower wise like experts oh
you're the real deal you're for real you
do you're like fetal hunting
so this is the Squints oh wow see thank
you for this education I didn't know all
that about him I could just say it's
another brand of celebrity like no he's
in there doing the work this is him
since he was younger and I asked him I
asked him about I'm not gonna go two
into it because I don't know if he wants
to share that but
I went on his podcast he started a
podcast like a year and a half ago I was
his first guest with Derby I don't know
if it ever came out but I did I did some
stuff with him but let's just say what a
nice dude all right what a cool shot
this one dude shout out to the whole
Squad yeah cool bro Smalls anyway here's
his weed on to the next thing uh go uh
let's let's let's let's do this was our
first time being on topics topics that
people other people you know because
we're not like
on the news we're not on people's stuff
we're not keeping up with Trends and
what's going on so Marty I like this
this is our first time dipping into the
so what do you think about so and so
uh-huh so let's dip into a podcasting I
guess you would say instead of
conversations with us by the way there's
cameras yeah basically that's pretty
much what it is but I think that's why
people like our show because it's just
like talking [__] with you I thought of
a funny segment on the way up here
what's it called all right so instead of
like you know how people have like
Celebrity Death poles
you know like you ever heard of that
like they bet on who who's gonna die
next oh I've heard that that's horrible
you want to do no no not that I'm just
saying like that all right in Reverse oh
so the opposite of that okay but who's
gonna your favorite you're a celebrity
that you like in life
at top one to three go that
you have to co-sign for it to the point
that they'll never get canceled okay I
love it you're what [__] to the point
that if they do get canceled for some
creepiness you got to go to jail too I
will 100 not back up anybody that I
don't know personally okay well there
goes a segment you know what because
that is scary I have to play it's not
that easy to do I was thinking on the
way up here I was like three celebrities
how uncreepy we are that that's the
segment
I love it I promise you guys we'll never
do some stupid [__] we've said it's a
season one I promise you yeah no that's
that goes about saying but it Disturbed
me how difficult it was to really sit
there and think about every celebrity
like that I like who would I really like
this dude for sure is never gonna have
anything crazy
I'm glad this is sad Marty
those
morals and by the way just because I
like it I go down with you too no
no all right that was awful so much for
that segment
y'all leave it in the comments he wanted
to bring it back I thought about it the
other day because we were talking about
I kind of reminding me of it when I was
talking about the way up here we were
talking about David Goggins and I'm like
that's a dude oh you never gonna get
canceled forever like in my heart take
it back
you're right there's a couple out
there's a couple people you could safely
bet on I'm a bet on David Goggins you're
right that's a celebrity I feel like Rob
Dyrdek's not getting canceled in this
lifetime true story
well I think it's a dangerous game to
play I think we're basically if we
didn't say your name we think you're a
[__] creep that's pretty much what
we're saying every single human we've
ever had on this show I can't know him
personally I forgot to say that oh okay
they gotta just be a celebrity in life
that you don't know personally uh what a
what a strategy for uh assessment you
gotta hit guests with this no they're
they that's them
which one of your friends do you bet on
is basically what you're saying
Marty I don't know about this one all
right all right you guys let us know you
let us know I'm gonna vote nay all right
but I will better I have a lot of ideas
for segments that are horrible
I'm not afraid to throw them out there
okay so now that we're talking about
topical thing oh my God that's what we
led into this with that's terrible
go go I pulled a couple of news topics
that I don't know anything about I was
wondering if you have a perspective on
some of these topics these are all
things that are hot in the news here
so Marty doesn't know about anything
except for work and what he's doing
I hear about stuff because I'm on the
internet sometimes I don't know about
[__] either but I but the topics you
picked pretty good ones I think I do
know about that okay thank you there you
go okay cool go for it okay there we go
so
I don't know much about this I don't
know if you're a fan of those
gentlemen's music prior to this whole
situation going on with them but the YSL
RICO case seems to be a never-ending
Saga of World Star videos yes you know
something I really like about the fact
that you put that in here is it's been
like three months since it started
everybody already talked about it and
now we're barely talking about it I love
it
I love it you know why
I have not
they don't have not much knowledge but I
have the knowledge of the gist and this
is you know what a lot of people get mad
like if you know what you're talking
about you shouldn't talk about I'm
telling you what I do know so we liked a
lot of things kind of set for a second
too let these simmer for a course it's
not like with raw we're like you know
what let's let this breathe for a minute
I will do that video we'll do a video
this week by the way how many people are
still just smoking raw papers I'd like
to know where do people stand on raw
papers currently now that like two weeks
has passed people switching up people
not
but also we don't know we're hoping that
we get Josh on here to go over real
quick there's a whole thing going on
with a lawsuit with raw
I'm no Josh for over a decade now one of
our best episodes he's only shown me
positive good things but we've had
trials and tribulations we've not been
happy with each other we have been
pissed off at each other we have not
worked with each other we've not talked
to each other we've been pissed off
pissed at you too we've both been pissed
like this is like a bit like Mutual a
mutual like bro
the [__] we've all done it to each other
and we both since talked but like my bad
for getting upset I'm like yo me too my
bad I was just talking you know I mean
not like yo I'm gonna fight you never
nothing he's a how many times I said
he's the most passive man in the world
how could you be mad at him yeah that's
what I always say to everybody like he's
too passive and great and nice to be mad
at very unique character very unique
person but also businessman
so we get into this we got into it a
little bit stuff happened anyway I'm
gonna do a video this week I'll talk
about everything because there's a lot
of the a lot of the lawsuit was about me
too so
do you want to explain that a little bit
uh just because you were like it's a
little fine line a little it's been
going on for like six years this lawsuit
yeah before I moved to LA it's been
going on the lawsuit that everybody just
found out all of these things back and
forth like the the start the spark of
this started like six seven years ago I
think oh okay from what I with
competitors yeah from what I'm talking
because OCB sued Raw
see this is a long story because then
you're gonna be like wait when did that
happen because OCB
to offered me a contract when I wasn't
working with Rob but I wasn't talking
about it publicly and stuff they offered
me three times Old Country Buffet
uh-huh oh OCB get out of here I'm just
gonna say I like ocbs I like elements I
like raws I don't give a [__] yeah like
whatever I didn't know the difference
until I started doing the face it anyway
um there's a lot of the lawsuit that I I
I'm gonna I'll do a full video on the
start of when I first talked to these
humans until last week because
I'll just say this
Josh FaceTime me a couple days after
everything happened
and even in the privacy of his own home
in my home he goes I cannot talk about
anything but let me just say
when I can I'll talk to you and we're
homies I'm in my own house and he
literally legit said I can't say
anything I'm like
oh that's scary bro we're on the phone
you're not going to say nothing I
wouldn't have forced you everybody come
on I left it but even in the Privacy
around home he was like I can't really
talk about it yet because it's kind of
still in the air because we're doing
some more [__] I was like oh it's not
over that's all I thought I was like oh
there's part two well after I sat with
it I felt like oh this could be there
could be a lot of things could be a lot
of technicality there is because like
Josh donates millions of dollars yeah if
he's not technically a real charity then
people like why aren't you what are you
hiding in all reality he's still
donating I don't know they're just I'm
not a lawyer I don't get it from what I
know and what I've read and what I know
personally if there's anybody on Earth
that has a good Insight it's this full
so I've been the master for eight years
seven years I've known this for almost a
decade I like that guy yeah I think he's
a good person but
I mean there's a long story but like
he's a bad person I mean like but
there's so many things there's a long
history between me and him it was a huge
long history
and you're all wrapped up and coming up
in business together and shows yeah it's
like a long because they're producing
all of my push trees because push trees
papers have been on hold for two years
because I'm lagging I've been so busy I
haven't really put my effort into it yet
and I was like why am I lagging and then
a week later this happened I'm like is
that why I was lagging because I would
have been caught up in some [__]
that doesn't have nothing to do with me
but since I got it produced by them do
you see what I'm saying like interesting
so I'm gonna ease the break I'm not
saying I'm not gonna do I'm still doing
push these papers and all my
representatives are gonna be called
paper pushers
there's paper pushers those trees paper
pushers great all of this is from Dunder
Mifflin push tree is a paper company
that's what it's going to be called by
the way everything is done is is because
I love the office
I can't wait anyway
um but just what would be so what was so
alarming about it
when you go back and watch the episode
it's just the idea of him being so
knowledgeable and so passionate and have
so many details of a life
live this way
it would be so insane it would be
detrimental doesn't actually like that
to the Earth he'd be the greatest actor
of all time okay look at that's my homie
I don't think any of that I mean on
paper whatever it is I don't know I know
that fool's not not donating this money
right I know he's not not doing what
he's doing but at the same time if it
were any to be true at all
that's my homie yeah like I don't know
if I could talk to you anymore
on a moral feeling but at the same time
it's like you're my friend and you're
going through something horrible yeah
do I you know what I'm saying like even
I'm not gonna say it but even when
somebody screwed me out of a legit
life-changing opportunity really wrote
my name off a contract when I was like
yo bro don't hit me up anymore don't
contact me blah blah but I even after we
went through this whole litigation I'm
like but if it's serious and you really
do need to talk to me
like on some friends here like we were
friends you can call me unless it's not
if it's not vital don't even bother me
never talk to me again I straight up
like don't ever bug me again if you see
me just just keep walking bro don't want
to shake your hand don't want to look at
you you can't believe you did this to me
like you [__] me on the biggest thing
I ever did like I would have been like
almost nine eight mil deep right now
damn
oh [__] [__] me out of my money
anyway cool I was gonna ask you like
this was I was gonna ask you separately
after editing the upcoming talking with
Thomas
a very sad story about betrayal of a
friendship in that I don't remember
which one with the surrounding push
trees
and a production company oh my God uh
and I only say that because we're
talking about it now but I was just
wondering like I was like your advice
that you give to young people when they
go through a betrayal like that and how
to deal with and I mean you just did it
but I was gonna ask that like how what's
nobody ever tells you how to deal with
like how to give people Second Chances
no one to not know when to cut somebody
off brutally oh know when to not be
really mean about it versus like you're
saying I went oh yeah because I don't
ever get even when people try to like
like that when this wolf screwed me out
of my share I worked two years on this
with this guy I'm not gonna get into it
I even said like bro something really
serious call me
but other than that and forget that
we're friends type of [__] it was such a
weird thing like yo don't talk to me no
nothing but if it's what did you mean
when you said that like like because he
was kind of sick at the time gotcha so
like if it's serious you [__] hit me
up other than that bro I can't be your
friend no more don't look at me don't
call me don't ever acknowledge me again
and it was sad as hell
it's my homie but he did some malicious
that [__] to me that's what I mean if
someone does something malicious to me
it's always the hardest thing because
you want to forgive those people it's
like there's a fine line between really
desperately wanting to forgive somebody
just to go back to being friends but
also standing up for yourself in a way
that you don't let people that do cross
certain lines with you be a part of your
life yeah and and what you're talking
about the push trees thing just a little
gist uh I got a uh uh that feels like my
big older brother like I considered him
like very close got you into the game
hold on man
and it was after like nine years of
working together is the weird thing nine
years yeah solid it just goes that that
says something that makes it super
actually so hard to try to scam me
this man was in the drill sergeant
like understandable man he's like 60
years old and trying to play me like
that hurt my soul bro I even told him
like bro you bro you hurt my feelings
[__] the money like this hurts my
feelings bro you're my friend it was
[__] you I went invited to my wedding
that's my homie he is awesome he's he's
helped without him push trees wouldn't
have ever survived he would front me
closed like maybe 30 days I'm like well
thank you I'm drowning over here making
content and not making any money so like
he kept me a word but then again I did
this return the favor the second he
needed it second I got Eddie Money like
whatever you need bro like no it's fine
don't do whatever it is I got you oh and
he saw that I helped him start his [__]
I saw all social media started I'm
starting to show I did a lot for this I
was supposed to be yeah because he was
he's his friend yeah and he played me
hard and I got it's over it's over but
did he shift into playing you later in
the relationship or was right when he
started doing bad and I was trying to
help him he was playing me on the back
end of me helping him
the cardinal sin of being a printer [__]
that wasn't out yet hmm
caught him on a social media post from
somebody else's I'm a [__]
investigator I was like what's that
voice what's that person who's that oh
that oh what did they follow went
through went through found a video of my
friend talking about scamming my [__]
what does this happen to be in the
background of a conversation and
somebody was doing something else to go
I know that voice on a on a random video
from a three weeks prior on this guy
post 70 times a day some random dude I
never even met and he was just in the
room yep and I heard that voice I know
it's like hearing an artist voice like
that's my friend I know that artist like
I know that voice and I just like
Rolodex like boom know whose face that
is
it's one of those things when you're
doing some devious [__] you're like I
know I'll get caught one day that's how
the universe
I heard the video
I know that kind of said the person's
name and he just stopped talking back on
hurt your feelings worse than the other
situation you're talking about yes even
though that one was like millions of
dollars I don't care back when I had no
it was 2015 has happened I was
struggling
this is [__] that I'm walking around
thinking about for years I let it go the
situation let it go after over it
like a week
genuinely
I'm not mad about it no more just like
Ugh
[__] [__] [__] they think of all
those times we're smoking and [__] yeah
Marty here I try to uh get you out of
your house I try to I try to try to
Swindle you out of your problem
I'm bearing bodies in your backyard you
know what I mean like hey
we smoke joints we hang out we go to
dinner like I know your wife you know
what oh no I'm gonna try to get you it's
the worst yeah I'm trying to sneak
attack you like bro I'm gonna kill you
that's how you feel but it's more like
please don't ever step foot around me
again you're the worst I'm gonna keep
going yeah
he's trying to get mad about it because
if you're mad then it's gonna stay
around the worst one you got a big ass
group of friends when you're a kid
like a teenager young adult and one of
them does some [__] like that to you but
you're still all in the same group of
friends and now you gotta hold up this
wall against this kid but you're you all
you got there's 10 of you that are all
best friends I never had to do like in
as kids because I I didn't care I would
just do something else but as an adult
when it got it's different when they
were in your life yeah
um
I've only had a few people try to play
me
but they were all always way older than
me each of them were like 25 years older
than me 20 years and then like 15. guess
that would make sense I don't know why
they're trying to get me like I was dumb
or something maybe because I'll be like
young and happy and like smiling yeah
they're probably thinking yeah
yeah I don't know but uh that happened
push trees on a bigger better oh I just
hired a creative director for push trees
boy finally took the step and hired a
creative director put him on salary and
I'm actually put them on salary
um
so yes on to this leads into our topic
here of like
so this YSL do you know who uh Young
Thug is no you don't he's a rapper he
thought he was real crazy I can't even
do his voice it's insane he sounds like
a trumpet sometimes and it's very cool
the way he messes with his voice he
sounds like a different instrument
sometimes he uses his voice differently
anyway
um germ Jilla I was in an apartment a
month before I moved to LA he showed me
post Malone Future and Young Thug and
said all three of these guys are gonna
come up soon they're all gonna be real
popular show me ezel from the bay too
and uh
he wasn't wrong I'll just say that
anyway he's a young thug he's like he's
a real killer though from Atlanta my
homie's on this she's like I think that
feels wild he wasn't telling me like
yeah he goes and murdered people he's
like that fool's real deal like he'd
make a music but that feels a murderer I
think he's like he was just saying like
damn I think that falls down out there
really doing the way he's like the way
he raps it sounds like he's really doing
this like he wasn't like snitching on
him he was just saying I think he's
actually doing some of this [__] he
sounds crazy but he's like his music's
tight
so what's going on with the RICO case
RICO case it's like reconnaissance or
whatever it's called basically they can
go back years and use all the evidence
years back prior against you it's it's
lawyer stuff that I have no business
explaining let's just say this well I
feel like I have a good understanding
after that so young thug and a bunch of
his say it right here Death Row Records
and everybody in it got arrested the
same day Marty yeah right and Snoop Dogg
is now on trial for all these murders
which is the main artist of yeah yeah
I'm saying so YSL Young Thug is the main
artist of that that rapper Gunna is a
rapper right I say Gunna all the time
g-u-n-n-a I spell it since I was a child
that's how I spell it because I think
it's funny in text and it looks funny
and everybody every time I say we're
gonna have a sick guess everybody's like
you're getting gonna on oh no that's why
they always say that and tag him and
then anyway okay I didn't get that
because I always spell it that way he
had to push piece all right so the
reason
I made a shirt five years ago and I said
I had a guy pushing a p
you might see it was like pushing peace
yeah I was like pushing peace
the worst selling shirt I ever made in
my life it's it's sold so slow then this
guy made a song called pushing Pete I
was like I'm remaking it a little
simpler sold out
he's a big artist right Marty
so they all went to jail and this guy
gonna apparently
everybody's saying the same thing
because they're like oh I just read it
on the internet he's out of jail
I from my perspective the only way you
get out of jail is taking a deal of some
kind because if you're on it for the
same reason
how are you out yeah and no one else is
so that fool is still in jail right now
one of the biggest artists in the world
Young Thug
oh
still a joke
kind of is not okay and everybody is uh
how many people are telling like
politics makes like the fact that this
is so in the news and it's all about
murders and Hood politics shows you
what the [__] is going on on Earth but
yo why are we highlighting this terrible
thing so much this is sad almost like
this guy's going to prison for life
probably he was a young artist a
millionaire and now he's probably never
get out that's sad anyway
um that's what's going on with that
Marty that's all I can tell you I
guarantee you there's a bunch of people
in the comments writing paragraphs
probably not a lawyer you're in it's
okay it's okay you know more than us
it's all right anything about this stuff
yeah we don't know but that's what I'm
getting from from about eight memes I
saw the clip of homeboy in the courtroom
walk up behind him and did you see that
[__] oh when they said that they
exchanged drugs or something but do
better and regarding it then if he can
do that you're slipping bro all right I
thought it would have been that easy
okay so what's your prediction in terms
of what his Fate's going to be at the
end of this oh I have no clue what they
do bring up rap lyrics
there's a song with a young thug talks
about taking it right on a certain or
taking a turn on a certain Street
shooting a man through a certain car and
someone getting shot while wearing some
I think it was a certain shirt
and then they bring up the the police
report man shot on them a certain car
with the colored shirt like bro did you
just describe the exact murder you know
what I'm saying like that is the most
you would think would happen more often
actually probably has but the fact that
the guy was saying it in court and
they're bringing up the murder was like
dude this is bad that's not even just
evidence you recorded it it's a
confession it out this is the confession
that was it was pretty damning it's
pretty damning bro unless everyone's
Spotify gets grabbed I'm pretty sure
they're going to use that one
you know what I'm saying it's hard I'm
like I'm saying like you've been sad
dude I mean obviously purple got
murdered is super waste way worse I get
that but wow what a way to get in
trouble on top to being so balling
that's the thing for me it's like you're
so bald already for a long time come on
you could do this but is this stuff he's
going down for from a long time ago I
have no clue
and I'm not I I'm not educated enough on
that yeah
let us know
um so on to the next topic you have and
I have very little knowledge uh that
dude Andrew Tate I had no idea who he
was until right before he got in trouble
yeah face Reign a couple weeks before
that because I don't know I just saw a
bunch of memes I saw a bunch of memes
people kept tagging me and thought you
could not be successful and get high
being smoking weed is for losers they
all sit at home and get high and be dumb
and then people kept tagging me on Tick
Tock I'm like why you tagging me in this
[__] hundreds of times and I went oh
These Guys Smoke mids they spoke trash
then or something because oh what are
you talking about man I'm not
look at these fools yeah stupid like but
I have no idea their beliefs I don't
watch any of the stuff I know he's kind
of misogynistic I know that he does
kickbox and he's bald his brother has
hair that's the gist I know nothing
about Andrew T because I just I've I've
a lot of [__] going on in life yeah so
I'm trying to do it all yeah so I don't
I don't know about him but I know he got
arrested headline is he just got another
30 days I had to do a sentence I have no
idea but what I know is I keep seeing
the man tweet because people just
retweet it definitely it seems like he
has a phone so it's like wait you have a
you have actually it's a Twitter in
prison Romania is like
what's happening so I that no idea
what's going on I don't get it Marty I
have no knowledge
that's it yeah you guys let us know yeah
you let us know oh there's a segment you
let us know because we're ignorant do
our research current events you tell us
about don't we care about because you
care about it but if you didn't I don't
give a [__] because it's like to really
speak on stuff you gotta really
knowledge research really dive into it I
see headlines like some of his accusers
are getting accused I don't even know
what he's in jail for it's an
interesting story they kind of watch
unfold but then again
I don't care
[Music]
it's really it yeah so is it positive
kind of a YouTube adjacent related story
yeah because I just don't know enough
and I I didn't that's it that's pretty
much it all right this next one Marty
this next topic it's crazy talk about
stuff that's not Jadakiss huh weird huh
so there's a rapper Marty his name is
Drake uh do you know of him I knew about
Drake before everybody
clipped that [__]
I love Degrassi no he's gonna be a
rapper I remember I remember I was away
from Canada over there oh
I just remember being in this hellhole
over collection agency am I like boy
that I worked with was it showed me a
picture of him and there's a dude in the
mall I got a picture with Drake and the
kid was like a little bit younger than
me like he was
19 if I was like 22 or whatever and I
could tell like oh this is for the
younger kids 10 years dad that'd be
right around when he was starting yeah
he was in Toronto and I had no clue who
he was but then I got his first mixtape
and I was kind of shocked that
successful with Trey Songz his he had a
song with Nipsey early on that whole
first mixtape was borderline damn Mark I
thought you were talking about your ass
right now
damn you got me uh I forgot that's what
except for all the Nickelodeon fans I
had to find that out later I I didn't
know he was I thought it was Lil Wayne
on this radio and I go oh it's not Lil
Wayne when he first came out we don't
sound a lot alike when I first came out
predicament where yeah you're a child
actor and then you're like okay I'm in
the basement I'm putting up I'm a rapper
too I'm putting on mixtapes out of the
basement
but then before
you even get before you even drop your
mixtape you get signed by Little Wayne
all right who's the greatest rapper of
all time in that moment the LeBron James
a wrap
you kind of start sounding like him
and then you guys go on to like take
over hip-hop and then you add on Nicki
Minaj and now Lil Wayne's like the Phil
Jackson of rap and he's the Superstar
himself man you really broke that down I
thought Marty was talking out his ass
good job damn okay that's a good way to
put it um I watched Degrassi all right
that's all I can say watched it as a
show I said I never watched it you got
all relieved oh okay no I never watched
it also I didn't like mainstream music
until I was like what until eight nine
years eight years ago because I didn't
give it a chance and we talked about I
was a hater I used to be a hater on
Drake but you mean everybody's the
greatest rapper ever and I would get
pissed like stop saying that job there's
moments like his [__] and that's when
I was being a hater yeah why why does it
matter if somebody else says he is what
the [__] does that matter to me that's
when I was ignorant at the time so if
you just said die I act like that too
you're ignorant you'll grow out of it
one day it'll pass because Greg Drake's
a pretty badass rapper I would say that
the music that is put out my oh I could
see why you're a major artist she's
pretty hard and you do a lot of
collaborations they're all pretty hard
all right you're cool I drink so now so
now the new album all right I get it 21
Savage you're getting the whole another
genre you're getting you did it with
future now who's popping hella hard 21
Savage let's do that one and who knows
it'll be next good little collaboration
piece he's like Jack used to collaborate
I don't even know what Jack is before I
do do you yeah oh so the jacket used to
collaborate with a bunch of different
artists like it was a burner's
ampichino's I think he did one with
LaRue Lee Majors uh uh anyway the Jack
of gold Bots he had so many things
amuccino drought Seasons traffic or
traffic was not him that was that was
amuccino and yeah you're going down to
some underground path I don't know I
just took out all my CDs the other day I
got original Mac Dre live from Fresno
jail original issue print I forgot I had
that and live from Fresno jail Mac Dre
the purple white and blue CD oh my God I
got an original print a Rubber Soul The
Beatles my favorite album I didn't even
know I had that [__] how I used
to be a CD collector Ralph my cousin
Ralph though I've been bringing he used
to run street light records in Santa
Cruz oh that's right that's why you
still go get all the CDs they go to this
Catalyst that's how I met Jack and all
these fools because so fresh clothing I
was a little friend and they would let
me cut the line I met Jack he signed a
bunch of my CDs I have the street album
two Thomas from The Jackal on I just
found it the other day like these are
memorable pieces I'll keep for the rest
of my life
oh my God so we got all talking about
Drake the jack is the greatest like all
right sorry anyway Drake and this guy uh
he's a rapper I know you probably don't
know who he is yeah his name I just
called him
I hate when they put the whole name it's
so hard to say x everybody called him
that he's a rapper he was pretty hard
different genre of music
my kids generation yes Charlie rocket
brought him up remember he brought him a
little brother big brother
and he started doing talking about the
bass
different sound honestly feels pretty
hard I like I liked a lot of his music
some of the slow [__] is pretty hard too
anyway apparently this is my take on it
apparently he's getting subpoena to go
into court over the murder case because
that dude got shot to death he got
murdered in like 2018 remember the day
having those hell said which seems
insane he got shot as a major artist
like for real whoa that's scary out here
anyway he got murked super sad kid young
kid and I remember that summer
him on live and someone posted it saying
and he was yelling at his phone like if
I get murdered it was Drake he keeps
saying it I was like damn this was being
bold is that a real statement or you
just you know people do fake rap beef
before an album comes out yeah so that's
what I thought it was thought nothing of
it this fool got murdered and then I've
seen a bunch of examples of like lyrics
and it could be adjacent to like
basically saying hey I did that [__]
saying Drake is taking history I know
Drake is saying we're like some of his
lyrics are kind of pointy like yo I did
that kind of like blatantly if you break
it down but everything is subjective
it's music it's art it could just be
whatever it means okay anyway and I I
don't know but he's being subpoenaed to
go into court about it that's as far as
I know because other than that I'm just
looking at [__] and I saw on the
internet like all you [__] I
think you're lawyers and [__] shut the
[__] up God I hate it then again it
doesn't bother me I mean it bugs now it
doesn't ruin my life who cares shut the
[__] up I'm just casually noticing
headlines here yeah we'll just keep
going because everybody on the internet
decides to be a lawyer when something
happens on the internet um it's just
weird to me that like
this artist in the world bro I hope he
says it's another sad case like yo if
this full ghost and gets in trouble for
this
another major artist is done that's some
scary [__] I mean do what you're gonna
do you have to go to jail but wow holy
[__] who would ever thought oh my God
the kid's gonna go to prison for her
whoa everybody thought she was solved
after it yeah oh [__] damn so anyway but
anyway softer not I'm just making a joke
it's sad someone's someone's dad a
little kid he was a young kid anyway
that's all I know about it seems so
right anything other than that I'm just
talking [__] and being ignorant because
I don't know much more
um good we'll let you know we'll let you
know more when we're venturing into
being ignorant talking [__] yeah I'll
let you know if I'm just being
completely ignorant uh Marty this last
one I have no idea what that is
oh well you know that you can go
obviously on Twitter you can pay for it
you pay for a verification I won't do it
but yes keep going no they're talking
about doing the same thing for Facebook
and Instagram
Mark Zuckerberg just posted this out
it was different I was gonna put my head
on the table what he's saying I think
again I didn't research his death is
essentially like
kind of providing the services that you
would have expected it to be originally
meaning this isn't I will charge you
basically we're going to charge you to
but it's a little bit different
we're going to charge you to go through
a vetting process to verify your page if
you're willing to provide your
government ID blah blah blah to prevent
people from making fraudulent pages
about you 150 times and we're going to
provide you customer support and you're
going to get more exposure on XYZ
explore page or whatever so they're
saying we're gonna so pay push your
social media that they should have been
doing in the first place this feels like
something that how it should have been
structured at the beginning yeah because
right now it's like okay you could say
the the check mark is a really good
it's only a status symbol right now it
has nothing to do with the scammer thing
because if that was the case
verification verification verify that is
Tony Hawk I mean that's Carrot Top for
real it's not what the [__] that yeah
because when you get behind the scenes
of the show you see like all it is or
who you know thing and who can you pay
to get it it's not we know that
performing as per like I've been a part
of projects where the page gets verified
zero post brand new account and I've
also paid people on Instagram thousands
of dollars a huge sketchy thing that's
really bias and we'll get you go to your
blog articles written I'm like okay
seven yeah like you only need five so
there's a it's a very subjective thing
it should be if they were to at the
beginning it really intended it to be a
system verified Pages for XYZ so you're
not getting fake Pages like you should
have just had to like qualify for it
like on Google you can get your Google
Business verified because they send you
a pin code at your address and all this
shout out to Spotify for verifying
Marty's page on Spotify without having
to pay you didn't have to ask right
yeah yeah
appreciate that foreign
not like pay for the verification it was
a lot of money and all I wanted for so I
can get a check mark by my name people
go you're real all the other Pete
there's thousands of my pages of me
selling packs people doing kick now it's
telegram I'm selling on Snapchat as it's
me I'm gonna you know how many death
threats I've gotten we talked about this
helpful's trying to kill me like I stole
from them and then takes 20 minutes to
break it down like bro I don't live
there I don't even have that and they're
like oh you do videos but you just
trusted a guy on the internet you didn't
even know it was me that's what blows my
mind bro they just get packed pictures
of me with 30 packs 100 packs go on Deck
with a number WhatsApp and then they
think it's me when they see me on the
podcast like that's the [__]
that stole how many people like send me
my address or not a more but used to
send me like uh I'll find you full money
you can research that but you can't
figure out yeah exactly between 20
followers on it you said this man four
thousand dollars you're stupid anyway
that used to happen I paid Instagram
[__] yeah I paid Instagram dudes there
they've blackmailed the [__] were not
blackmailed me stolen stolen my money
many times I've lost a car over trying
to get my page back trying to get a
check mark just to verify so people stop
getting scammed and no it's me still
hasn't happened but you know what so
okay I have some legitimacy in that
that's what I was for no it's me for
real I really I do have these articles I
am oh Forbes is reputable yeah got it
yeah x amount of hundred millions of
views yeah History Channel
how many things do you need and they say
oh no and one more gotcha
out of your field History Channel but it
would be great to have customer service
like if it's something that you would
like Instagram becomes a part of our
careers basically especially at this
point man so it's like yeah it would be
great if it was like a regular company
had customer service I'm like
you know like that's not crazy to think
about it's about you know it's like when
it becomes a business Yeah so basically
um yeah you can buy [__] now I don't
think it matters anymore because
anything goes away at this point it's
like well anybody could get verified and
start trapping it out
I guess no they can just dot into the
DMs I used to be a drug dealer sir I
understand all the little loops and
tricks you make a you know I'm not gonna
explain that never mind because there's
a little process you could do and if you
get people they're stupid as hell don't
trust anybody in their internet that say
they're gonna sell to you this is a
company
and it's reputable and you can Google it
and you know and actually see that it's
a real company and you're in a legal
State because if it's a legal state
they're illegal
anyway that's it all right last that was
it so let's get on to this last thing I
want to talk about before we get out of
here because I think it's important and
then we'll get out of here guys
um you know me I know me you guys too I
complain about my stomach all the time
my stomach hurts since I was a kid and
my stomach always hurts right
um You already know I don't eat meat or
cheese so that's cut out so what else
hurt my stomach I don't know I stopped
drinking soda because my stomach was
hurting go to the doctor doing the tests
uh he's like yo I need you to take a
food allergy test I'm like good idea
ever since I went vegan I started eating
like just ah it's vegan I'll eat it that
means Oreos are vegan that doesn't mean
they're good for you I'll eat Oreos like
oh hell yeah junk food I'll eat that
[__] oh soy Burger give me that she'll
eat that right now so take whatever you
can get yeah that's what I was doing for
so long I always felt like [__] you can
be vegan and unhealthy it's cold eating
processed [__] yeah it's not just
because it's not meat doesn't mean it's
healthy stop eating I was eating a bunch
of sewing [__] anyway I'm like you know
what I'm gonna cut out soy so cut out
soy did the food allergy test the lady
looks at me damn the lady looks at me
and says it's 78 Pricks in your back
it sounds hella terrible I'm sorry
it's 78 Polk damn it she's gonna poke my
back right here or whatever 78 times
when I was a kid it was like a board it
was but they're different ones now
they're little individuals now they do
separate different sections for
different allergies so they know what to
read it how to read it better like a
chart the chart your back basically
anyway and I'm like wait needles I
freaked out you know my fear of needles
she's like nah don't trip a little
[__] [__] turn over and she started
doing it doctor comes in food allergy
test test me on everything under the sun
you can be tested for it because
something's hurting my stomach my
stomach hurts all the time
I'd take things out I'm sorry you know
what I mean like I stopped eating
process [__] still hurts
and I'm like it's got to be something it
has to be something crazy
or something simple something's got to
change
he walks in and goes You're Gonna Hate
Me
he goes don't worry you still ate
burgers and [__] I don't eat me and he
goes oh all right well you still eat
pizza like I don't eat cheese he goes oh
you're gonna hate me
are you ready
I eat sandwiches and bird I eat avocado
and Sprout sandwiches almost every day
thinking I'm being healthy yeah I'm
allergic highly are you ready he goes
sit down ready I go damn bro what
what is it he goes you're not deathly
allergic but you're you're allergic to
wheat
he goes and these are the 20 words that
mean we flower uh starch tapioca this
that potato any kind of starch any flour
tortillas bread muffins cookies I'm
allergic to anything in the world that
has wheat in it
that's what my stomach hurts all the
time I was like I'm just eating
eating things every day that inflamed my
stomach every day and I was telling like
too much like [__] hurts something's
wrong with my stomach so I'm getting
sitting here with inflamed intestines
every day
ready no I'm not done we highly allergic
to Soy what have I been replacing since
I went vegan I've eaten soy which is the
burgers soy sauce
vegetable broth because it has soy in it
any kind of modified starch any starch
whatsoever I cannot eat french fries
anymore sir
not good news for a vegan
because it's not like oh I eat turkey
and vegetables and chicken and steak
it's fine it's not done yeah pistachios
who gives a [__] but [__] pistachios
highly allergic to peanut didn't know
that my whole life maybe I eat peanut
butter all the time every day bro my
protein shakes are all peanut butter
flavored all of them all my snack bars
are all peanut butter ones because
there's only ones I like from that damn
brand I buy boxes of them
and then he said flaxseed oil and
flaxseed which is in all health bars all
my vegan she has flaxseed in it all the
ones I just put to the store for I read
every package of the day I got home
every one of them supposed to be healthy
for you I think it is if you're not
allergic to flaxseed and then he said
cotton seed oil goes ah who gives a [__]
he goes That's What preserves things
they go what do you mean goes anything
in a package you basically can eat
you know even if it's wrong
so I was like yo so what can I eat and I
wrote it down like
[__] that I'm supposed to
raw vegetables and plants but the thing
that's hard is like I can't eat
tortillas that's hard but at least she
didn't say you're allergic to bean and
rice yeah I would have been pissed I
would have just there's got to be some
option for like sir no I found it I
found it I went through the entire bread
aisle to be 30 minutes and I found one
single bread that didn't have starch
tapioca starch no modifiers no
[__] there's like everything's good
and then one thing at the end like oh
damn it bro I you know what I've eaten
I've eaten four times in like five days
because I just don't know what to eat
dude I'm eating vegetables and fruits
and [__] and then like all right but it
goes for so long you ready you ready
yeah I'll end it with this guys my
stomach doesn't hurt at all
first episode
I told you yeah every time I work out
I'm like oh my stomach I go to the
bathroom like I'm on the constant verge
of like should I go to the bathroom or
should I wait that's my whole life
driving I'm like how far
stomach hurts though that's my whole
life every day on top of my back hurting
it's the word and then my arches broke
I'm like yo you're falling apart stop
being so fat so that's what I'm doing
and then I finally built my whole gym
I've been I'm on day two David Goggins
100 reps of everything you should have
seen him in Ralph I'm hurt you don't
realize how heavy that treadmill is
a glass staircase without touching
anything it was real fun it sucked
um anyway we're gonna change it we're
all we're on the way all right day two
of the gym in my house my own house I
built a gym guys we took two rooms and
built them out like a gym I'm so excited
and uh yeah that's what I did this
morning that we came here
and then I got high
we're doing good all right we're trying
to be healthy but anyway my stomach
doesn't hurt nearly as much hurt a
little bit this morning but I don't know
what that's from
here we are let's go so if you're out
there and you have these stomach
problems you always wonder what's going
on it could lead to skin issues she said
get tested irritation go get to it's
like 150 bucks does it hurt what you are
allergic to because you never did it
hurt not really yeah it felt like uh
when little kids do this
yeah and squeeze you real quick yeah it
felt like that I remember it was just
like a little a little poke but it
didn't break your skin that's what made
me stoked but it was like did it itch if
you were allergic to it it gets real big
red and bumpy if it is if it's if you're
allergic that's how you we walked in and
goes oh you're gonna hate me all you do
is look at my back my back was all bumpy
and red and gross so yeah
um there we go
foreign
yeah drop a comment do you like this
usually Marty's here we put the camera
to the side different Studio different
setup you guys let us know I like
cutting stuff out it will slightly turn
it a little more next time broadcasters
I like this this is cool
um and one as of the day as of Monday
when this comes out I'm gonna Premiere
my first YouTube video or the following
day I think Tuesday yeah well we'll hype
it up following party it's Marty made it
on Instagram all right and right here
this is my name same one dope not same
one there you go
um I think that's it man it's a cool
little wrap-up episode for all the fans
that are still with us at the end of the
episode why don't we let them know this
new guest that we just booked for
midnight oh there we go all right so
like we said
Mario may not have heard this man before
but I know your daughter is going nuts
I've heard of this rabbit before just
because I I try to stay up on the new
[__] I stay on you know Spotify again I
stay on Spotify the new new artist or
whatever and I heard this dude like a
year and a half ago and I'm like
all right stop I can see why it falls
like this that uh nle Choppa the rapper
I think he's awesome I think the guy's
cool on top of that we just booked his
ass he's coming in like two weeks I hope
he smokes to that I hope he's ready to
get high as hell if he smokes but the
thing I [__] with this guy he's a high
raw vegan diet he's like alkalized dude
he makes his own deodorants and face
masks like he's on like deworm your body
be up meditate you're centering yourself
like this Fool's like and then it's like
rapper attire like the best contrast
ever yo this was that one with himself
by the way nice chain
nice car [__] that's how I feel like
yeah sick I love this car I just drink
water now let's just drink water to eat
grapes like I can't eat anything else
I'm so sad about it it sucks Marty I I
have this many peanuts in my that's the
worst that's what I survive on that's
what I live off of you say it too I'm
allergic it's some [__]
gotta flip it around and do a blessing
no I did you know what
I'll be healthier done [__] it I was
trying not to debrid anyway Andrew
Schultz photo he bred at all he's tall
and skinny what if I just get like four
inches taller growing [__] my allergy
was done your arches form backing just
get huge I'm sick
um all right let's just get out of here
anything else you want to say thank you
guys we appreciate you all right
um guys thank you so much for being here
this has been another episode of the
dope as usual podcast this is a bit
about me and Marty just talking [__] and
ranting all right headstones to new
rappers to my back hurts and my stomach
but we're getting better guys sure did
it almost oh okay all right bro all
right guys thank you so much for being
here once again leave a like before you
get out of here this has been the dope
as usual podcast today we talked about
life drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between have a dope ass
day
that's clean outro sauce on these
[__] outros I know right that was
pretty good all right
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie